Salut ! Après un an et demi de vidéos, de spectacle et d'écriture de livre,
j'ai décidé de faire une pause cet été.
Pour me reposer, oui, mais aussi pour vous préparer une renaissance de la chaîne en septembre.
Je vous ai demandé sur Twitter si vous vouliez quelques facts rapides et divertissants en attendant.
Alors pendant ces 60 jours de pause, je vous laisse une vidéo rapide et sans prétention tous les jours pairs à 11H.
On se retrouve à la rentrée.
Et... tout de suite.
Est-ce que vous pensiez vraiment que Geogre Washington cultivait du cannabis ?
Salut ! Aujourd'hui je vous parle de trucs qui m'a fait marrer quand moi je l'ai lu la première fois.
Je me suis renseigné, et c'est vrai, à 18 ans, George Washington était cultivateur.
Il était agriculteur.
Et en Virginie à cette époque là, on cultivait du coton, du tabac ou du chanvre.
Le chanvre, qui servait à faire des cordages, qui servait à faire des vêtements...
Et la vraie question qu'on se pose, historiquement parlant et surtout ceux qui font le lobby du cannabis  aujourd'hui c'est:
Est-ce qu'il le consommait ?
Est-ce que George Washington fumait son propre cannabis ?
Alors on a retrouvé son journal, et dans son journal il y a un indice à l'intérieur.
En 1765, mai 65, ça a été vraiment la grande époque du cannabis.
Et là on sait qu'à cette époque là, il récoltait à peu près 500 kilos.
Qui est plutôt une belle production...!
Mais ce qui est plus perturbant, c'est que dans son journal il explique comment on peut séparer les mâles plants des plants femelles.
Et ça pour faire du textile ou des cordages, on s'en fou un peu...
Le seul interêt c'est que dans les plants femelles du cannabis, c'est là qu'on trouve le THC, qui est la substance psychotrope active.
Le but du jeu c'est que le plant mâle ne féconde pas le plant femelle.
Bon, au final on est quand même sûr de rien.
Il n'y a pas de vraie hypothèse sérieuse sur le sujet.
Puisqu'on peut aussi séparer les plants mâles des plants femelles,
simplement parce que les plants mâles ont apparemment des fibres un petit peu plus solides, et des tiges un petit peu plus solides,
donc pour la production c'est mieux.
Alors que les plants demelles, elles fournissent des graines
et on peut les séparer pour se dire qu'on va replanter grâce à ça.
Quoi qu'il en soit le sujet était assez drôle.
Il méritait d'être abordé au moins une fois durant cette série de l'été où je vous fais une vidéo tous les deux jours
jusqu'au 30 août.
J'espère que ça vous a plu.
Si c'est le cas, n'oubliez pas de liker ou de vous abonner à la chaîne.
Et rendez-vous dans deux jours.
Forcément. Après-demain.
Ciao !
[musique]